resuelve la ecuación 5 entre x 1 igual a
3 entre x 3 con 2 restricciones que es
que x no puede ser igual a menos 3 ni a
1 aunque ahora estas restricciones están
allí para que estas expresiones
racionales no se determinen aunque si
tuviéramos x igual a menos 3 aquí este
denominador sería igual a 0 y esta
fracción estaría indeterminada y lo
mismo si x fuera igual a 1 este
denominador sería igual a 0 y esta
expresión racional estaría indeterminada
aunque entonces pues vamos a resolverla
y para tener espacio en donde trabajar
vamos a reescribir la por aquí
5 / x 1 igual a 3 / x + 3 muy bien muy
bien bueno resulta que a mí no me gusta
sin nada nada pero nada tener términos x
en el denominador de ninguna expresión
racional entonces vamos a ver cómo lo
vamos a hacer para sacar esta x del
denominador
y una buena forma de hacer eso es x x +
ok para que se cancelen ya la sacamos
del denominador entonces tenemos que
multiplicar del otro lado también por x
+ 3 porque como esta es una ecuación
aquí tenemos un símbolo de igual todo lo
que le hagamos al lado derecho se lo
tenemos que hacer al lado izquierdo
así es que multiplicamos de los dos
lados por x + 3 con el objetivo de que
este se cancele con este porque recuerda
que seguimos con la restricción de que x
sea distinto de menos 3 y b 1 esta
restricción la vamos a asumir a lo largo
de todo este vídeo bien entonces de esa
forma hicimos que no haya términos x en
el denominador de esta expresión
racional y ahora pues nos gustaría hacer
lo mismo con esta x no o sea no nos
gusta que haya x en el denominador
porque entonces es más complicado
decidir a que tiene que ser igual x así
es que vamos a multiplicar x
x menos uno de los dos lados del igual
entonces este se cancela con este porque
esto es distinto de cero porque x tiene
que ser distinta de uno y listo ya no
tenemos términos x en ningún denominador
y lo que nos queda es x más 3 x + 3 x 5
x 5 igual a 3
3 x x menos uno por x menos 1 gay esta
ecuación con esta restricción es
igualita a esta otra ecuación con esta
misma restricción que hay aquí no se nos
olvide x tiene que ser distinto de menos
3 y 1 voy a dejar de escribirlo en todas
las ecuaciones a lo largo de todo el
vídeo vamos a asumir que x es distinto
de menos 3 y de 1 y realmente lo único
que hicimos aquí fue multiplicar a ambos
lados del igual por los dos
denominadores y nos quedó esto y bueno
de aquí es de donde sale todo ese método
de la multiplicación cruzada que te dice
que tienes que multiplicar este por este
y este por éste si te fijas justo eso es
lo que tenemos aquí pero eso proviene
justo de esta idea de multiplicar de los
dos lados por ambos denominadores gay y
ya que tenemos esto esto ya es una
ecuación simple que ya sabemos cómo
resolver nada más tenemos que dejar las
x solitas de un lado del igual
y listo ya sabremos a cuánto tiene que
ser igual a equis entonces pues vamos a
hacerlo
a ver para resolver esta ecuación
primero tenemos que distribuir este 5
por este paréntesis así es que nos queda
5 x + 5 por 3 15 igual lo mismo
distribuimos de este lado y nos queda 3x
menos 3
ahora queremos todas las x de un mismo
lado así es que vamos a restarle 3x a
este lado para que se cancele con esta
así es que lo tenemos que hacer de este
lado también
entonces nos queda 5 x menos 3x eso es 2
x + 15 + 15 es igual a 3 x 3 x este se
cancela con este y nos queda simplemente
menos 3 - 3 entonces siguiendo con eso
de dejar a la x solita vamos a restar 15
de los dos lados y nos queda 2 x 2 x más
15 menos 15 0 igual a menos 3 menos 15 o
sea menos 10 y 8 y finalmente dividimos
entre dos de los dos lados este se
cancela con este y nos queda que x es
igual a menos 18 entre 2 que es igual a
menos
gay x es igual a menos 9
ok entonces veamos si x menos 9 en
efecto resuelva esta ecuación aunque
estamos verificando nuestra respuesta
estamos diciendo que si x es igual a
menos 9 entonces esto si es igual a esto
hay es una suerte que x no haya sido
igual ni al menos 3 ni a 1 pero bueno
vamos a sustituir x igual a menos 9 en
este lado de la ecuación porque tenemos
aquí 5 entre menos 9 menos 1 y eso es
igual a 5 entre menos 10 que a su vez es
igual a menos un medio ok entonces si
sustituimos x igual a menos 9 obtenemos
que esto de aquí es igual a menos un
medio ahora vamos a ver cuánto nos queda
si sustituimos x igual a menos 9
este el lado de la ecuación que tenemos
aquí 3 / x que es menos 9 + 3 y eso es
igual a 3 entre menos 93 menos 6 que es
igual a menos un medio entonces sí
cuando sustituimos x igual a menos nueve
obtenemos que este lado si es igual a
este lado
ok porque los dos lados nos quedó menos
un medio entonces hemos verificado que x
es igual a menos 9 si resuelve la
ecuación y al fin y al cabo no era
necesario poner esta restricción porque
x igual a menos 9 es el único valor en
todos los reales que hace que este lado
sea igual a esto es el único real que
resuelve esta ecuación